shell-shocked survivors left to pick
through what's left of their homes
emergency workers had tried to warn
towns that a flood was coming
but in valportheim in west germany's
rhineland paletonate
residents say they had almost no time to
react
before their homes were hit by raging
flood waters
all of a sudden the water breached the
dam
all the houses here are the same height
so when the water came up from the
cellar at lightning speed
we all jumped in our cars and drove up
the mountain
we had to get ourselves to safety
towns don't have electricity or clean
water
internet has been cut off and phone
reception is down
volunteers have come from nearby areas
bringing whatever equipment they had
to help clear roads and houses
yeah i've been here angercom when i
arrived here it was a catastrophe
the entire road behind me was covered in
branches and wrecked cars
all mashed into one up to this height
you couldn't access the buildings left
and right
and we didn't know what we would find in
the rubble we were warned that we might
come across bodies and that we should
alert the fire brigade and the police
many towns are still cut off from help
some major roads are flooded or broken
apart
the authorities say overflowing dams
could still burst
threatening more homes and forcing
residents to stay clear of the area
while the weather has cleared in some
areas more rain
is expected well there are several areas
across western germany affected by this
flooding
and dw's julia saudelli is on the ground
for us
in rhineland-palatinate she is in the
city of
valportheim tracking the latest for us
there let's bring her in now julia
tell us what the situation is like where
you are
started here to move on from the initial
shock of what happened and actually
taking stock
of the real damage that has occurred
here as you
can see here behind me there is debris
strewn all over the streets
mud inside the homes it is filled with
mud windows and doors have been torn
away
and people are slowly starting to clean
up we don't see
many authorities or firefighters here
helping clean up there are a lot of
volunteers who came
to this town with tractors and other
equipment to try to
clean up the streets a lot of them are
farmers from the neighboring
region and we spoke to one of these
volunteers and asked them what he saw
when he first arrived here in the town
let's have a listen
yeah i've been here when i arrived here
it was a catastrophe
the entire road behind me was covered in
branches
and wrecked cars all mashed into one up
to this height
he couldn't access the buildings left
and right and we didn't know what we
would find in the rubble
we were warned that we might come across
bodies and that we should alert the fire
brigade
and the police
it was all very uncertain and we were
working with our own tools
that we brought with us
julia we hear there really is all hands
on deck in what is an
unstable situation still and we're
hearing reports that in the region there
are still
1300 people unaccounted for
is there any update on finding those
people
yeah this is news we heard uh yesterday
evening
from the authorities here in the region
and uh we haven't heard
of an update since then they the
authorities are hoping that
these people that are unaccounted for
that it is because
the communication via telephone and
internet is very spotty very difficult
at the moment and that's
why they can't reach all these people uh
but there is fear that there will be
more dead discovered and found in the in
the coming hours
julia we see some of the destruction
there behind you can you give us an idea
or is there an idea already of
how big the damage is
authorities haven't yet given a number
or an amount for
how much the damage amounts to in terms
of
money but as we see here it is a serious
situation there are
entire trees and cars strewn across
streets
mud everywhere the ground floors of
homes are completely inundated with mud
and it's going to take time and money to
clean up the town here and to start
rebuilding
afterwards dw's julia saudelli reporting
there with the very latest from
valpo time thank you
it's not just germany that's
experiencing heavy rains and flooding
neighboring belgium and the netherlands
have both seen unusually heavy downpours
rising water levels caused rivers to
burst their banks
sending water gushing through the
streets belgian authorities have
reported
12 deaths and they're urging people to
seek higher ground to stay safe
perched precariously on their rooftops
these residents in the belgian province
of liege are doing all they can to stay
dry
the high waters forced them to take
refuge where they could
get a catastrophe in 60 years i've never
seen
anything like this so it's really
unusual
and i think that it's going to cause a
lot of trouble for a lot of people
residents are relieved to get to safety
but also devastated by what they've had
to leave behind
you i'm relieved but i've lost
everything
i live on the ground floor and there on
the ground floor everything has been
destroyed
it was hard i had to open the door of my
mother's bird cage so the bird could
escape
but my three cats are still up there
in the netherlands lindbergh province
has also been hit with flash floods and
heavy downpours
thousands of people have been evacuated
the army has been sent in to help rescue
and flood prevention efforts